اسابيع من المفاوضات وصلت الى طريق مسدود
حتى الان بين الطرفين فما الذي يعيقه صفقه
سقف الديون
نقطه الخلاف الاولى هي وضع حد اقصى لمقدار
الانفاق الحكومي للميزانيات الفيدراليه
المستقبليه كما اقترح الجمهوريون
الجمهوريون ايضا يرغبون بوقف مساعدات
قصائم الطعام والمساعدات الماليه الطبيه
الخلاف الثالث هو الاموال غير المنفقه
التي كانت مخصصه لدعم الشركات وحكومات
الولايات التي تتعامل مع جائحه كورونا من
قبل وزاره الخزانه
نقطه خلاف اخرى هي تصاريح الطاقه وما اذا
كان يجب تسهيل منح الحكومه الفيدراليه
تصاريح للشركات الخاصه لمشاريع تطوير
الطاقه مثل التنقيب عن النفط وبناء محطات
الطاقه
ويتخوف الكثيرون من تعذر الولايات المتحده
عن سداد ديونها البالغه اكثر من 31
تريليون دولار ما قد يؤدي الى ازمه وفوضى
عالميه الا ان محللين يقولون ان تاثير هو
ان الاقتصاد العالمي سيتباطا كما ان
معدلات الرهن العقاري قد ترتفع بالاضافه
الى السلع المهمه كالنفط
والقمح
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات